From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. It's a summer evening in Northern Indiana. Three teenagers are in their car, headed to a church sponsored volleyball game. It's 1978. The three Ulrich girls, sisters Judy and Lynn and their cousin Donna, drive down US-33 in a Ford Pinter. Judy is behind the wheel. She's 18, a recent high school graduate. Two years older than her little sister Lynn. Donna is also 18. Around 6.30, Judy slows down. She's worried she might have left the cap to the gas tank on the trunk. She puts on her hazard
这里是NPR的《Hidden Brain》，我是Shankar Vedantam。那是印第安纳州北部的一个夏夜。三名少女正乘车前往一场由教会赞助的排球比赛。时间是1978年。Ulrich家的三个女孩——姐妹Judy和Lynn以及她们的表亲Donna，正开着一辆福特Pinto行驶在33号公路上。Judy坐在驾驶座上。她18岁，刚高中毕业，比妹妹Lynn大两岁。Donna也是18岁。大约6点30分，Judy减慢了车速。她担心自己可能把油箱盖忘在后备箱上了。她打开了危险警示灯。
lights. A few seconds behind the pinto on the same road, Roger Dugger is driving a Chevy van. He is looking for a cigarette pack on the floor. When he looks up, the slowing pinto is right in front of him. He's going about 50 miles per hour, and he doesn't have time to stop. At first, Roger doesn't think the crash is that bad. Then, he smells gasoline. Later, reporters will recount testimony from a third driver who saw what happened. There was a puff of flame about 12 to 18 inches long at the rear of the car. Almost immediately, the pinto explodes into flames. He said it was like a large napalm bomb going up.
在同一条路上，紧随Pinto车后几秒钟，Roger Dugger正开着一辆雪佛兰面包车。他当时正在地板上找一包香烟。当他抬头时，减速的Pinto车就在他正前方。他的车速大约是每小时50英里，根本来不及刹车。起初，Roger觉得撞击并不严重。接着，他闻到了汽油味。后来，记者们转述了一位目击了事发经过的第三位司机的证词。车尾出现了一团约12到18英寸长的火焰。几乎就在瞬间，Pinto车爆炸起火。他说那就像一颗大型凝固汽油弹爆炸了。
Is it creamed down the highway and finally came to a stop. It was burning all the way. The eyewitness gets out of his car with a fire extinguisher and runs over to see if he can help. But he said the temperature and the heat was so intense that it was too hot to stay close to the car for very long. By the time the first state trooper arrives, the pinto is scorched. Inside the car, Lin and Donna are dead. Judy is outside alive, but badly injured. She's taken to a burned unit at a nearby hospital. She lives for about nine more hours.
它沿着高速公路滑行，最终停了下来。它一路都在燃烧。目击者拿着灭火器下车跑过去看能否帮忙。但他表示，当时的温度和热量太强烈了，以至于根本无法在车旁停留太久。当第一位州警赶到时，Pinto车已经被烧焦了。车内，Lynn和Donna已经死亡。Judy在车外还活着，但受了重伤。她被送往附近医院的烧伤病房。她又活了大约九个小时。
Before she dies, Judy tells the police what happened. She also asks the nurse if her sister and cousin are okay. The nurse tells her they lived. Six months later, Judy and Lynn's mother get something in the mail from the Ford Motor Company. It's a recall notice for the car her daughters were killed in. The Ford Pinto. Today, we speak to a Ford insider who has asked himself a painful question.
在去世前，Judy告诉警察发生了什么。她还问护士她的妹妹和表亲是否安好。护士告诉她她们活下来了。六个月后，Judy和Lynn的母亲收到了一封来自福特汽车公司的邮件。那是她女儿们丧生的那款车的召回通知。福特Pinto。今天，我们采访了一位曾问过自己一个痛苦问题的福特内部人士。
Should he have done more to get the Pinto off the road? Certain circles on the certifiable villain, guilty of not protecting innocent, unsuspecting people, driving a patently dangerous car. This week on Hidden Brain, the minefield of hindsight bias. While knowing how something turned out, shapes the way we think about everything that came before it, and the insidious effect this has on our lives. Our story today starts with long ago events,
他是否应该做更多努力让Pinto车退出市场？在某些圈子里，他是公认的恶棍，犯有不保护无辜、毫无防备的人的罪行，让他们驾驶一辆明显危险的汽车。本周的《Hidden Brain》，我们将探讨后见之明的偏见这一雷区。了解事情的结果如何，会如何塑造我们对之前发生的一切的看法，以及这种偏见对我们生活产生的阴险影响。我们今天的故事始于很久以前的事件，
but it's not really about the past. It's about how, in the present, we think about the past, about the profound bias that shapes such thinking and the effect this bias has on our lives. We begin in 1970. The American car industry was dominated by a handful of major companies. There was General Motors, there was Chrysler, and there was another big one. Ford. There was General Motors, there was Chrysler, and there was another big one. Ford.
但这并不是关于过去。它是关于在当下，我们如何思考过去，关于塑造这种思维的深刻偏见，以及这种偏见对我们生活的影响。我们从1970年开始。当时的美国汽车工业由少数几家大公司主导。有通用汽车，有克莱斯勒，还有另一家巨头。福特。有通用汽车，有克莱斯勒，还有另一家巨头。福特。
What makes Mustang number one? Prisonality. Elephants. For a new decade. The 1970 Thunderbird. Ford, the wagon master. But the new decade marked the end of an era of carefree car buying in America.
是什么让野马成为第一？个性。大象。为了一个新的十年。1970年的雷鸟。福特，旅行车之王。但这个新十年标志着美国无忧无虑购车时代的终结。
of an era of carefree car buying in America. The country was shedding its innocence. Young men were being drafted into the Vietnam War, and the Nixon administration would soon be marred by scandal. Two books, Rachel Carson's Silent Spring, and Ralph Nader's unsafe at any any speed were in the zeitgeist. More and more, cars were seen no longer as a symbol of freedom, but as a social problem. American car companies felt on the siege from federal regulations at home and competition from abroad.
美国无忧无虑购车时代的终结。这个国家正在褪去它的天真。年轻人被征召参加越南战争，尼克松政府很快也将陷入丑闻。两本书——蕾切尔·卡森的《寂静的春天》和拉尔夫·纳德的《任何速度都不安全》——成为了时代的精神。汽车越来越多地不再被视为自由的象征，而被视为一个社会问题。美国汽车公司感到受到国内联邦法规和国外竞争的围攻。
Consumers were turning away from American cars to Mercedes-Benz's from Germany, sleek jaguars from Britain, and small, fuel-efficient Toyota's and Honda's from Japan. In 1969 alone, one million cars were imported into the United States. If American car companies wanted to keep up, they needed to match what their competitors were offering. Ford's answer was an inexpensive, fuel-efficient, subcompact car, the Pinto. This is an advertisement introducing the car. It shows a fall, presumably a Pinto horse, alone in a field.
消费者开始背离美国汽车，转而购买德国的梅赛德斯-奔驰、英国时髦的捷豹，以及日本小巧、省油的丰田和本田。仅在1969年，就有100万辆汽车进口到美国。如果美国汽车公司想跟上步伐，他们就需要匹配竞争对手提供的产品。福特的回答是一款廉价、省油的超小型汽车——Pinto。这是一则介绍该车的广告。它展示了一匹小马，大概是一匹Pinto马，独自在田野里。
The horse gets to its feet and gallops around a banana yellow Ford Pinto car. The commercial introduces a slogan for the car that would only become ironic later on. The little carefree car. Ford's president at the time, Leia Eccocca, had pushed for the Pinto when he was still a vice president of the company. He was set to have called the car, his baby. The company codenamed the car his baby. The company codenamed the car Phoenix. Again, the irony of this nickname would not be evident until much later. To boost gas mileage and reduce costs, the
小马站起来，围着一辆香蕉黄色的福特Pinto车奔跑。广告为这款车引入了一句后来才变得讽刺的口号。那辆无忧无虑的小车。福特当时的总裁李·艾柯卡在担任公司副总裁时就力推Pinto。据说他称这款车为他的“宝贝”。公司将这款车代号为“凤凰”。同样，这个绰号的讽刺意味直到很久以后才显现出来。为了提高油耗表现并降低成本，
Pinto had a stripped down minimalist design. Cars usually have a steel frame that supports the engine, the transmission, the wheels and so on, and a body that goes on top of that. But the Pinto had just one piece. The body was the frame. Executives at Ford were said to have mandated that their employees build a car that weighed 2000 pounds and cost 2000 dollars. Then, in 1973, something happened that made the Pinto a bonafide winner for Ford. The OPEC nations have decided to cut oil production by 5% and continue cutting their oil production by an additional 5% each successive month until Israel withdraws from occupied-hour blends. And the rights of Palestinian refugees is restored. In October, the Organization of Petroleum Exporting Countries, OPEC, slapped an embargo on oil ship to the United States.
Pinto采用了精简的极简主义设计。汽车通常有一个支撑发动机、变速箱、车轮等的钢制框架，上面再覆盖车身。但Pinto只有一个部件。车身就是框架。据说福特的高管要求员工制造一辆重2000磅、成本2000美元的汽车。然后，在1973年，发生了一件事，使Pinto成为福特名副其实的赢家。欧佩克国家决定将石油产量削减5%，并在此后每个月继续额外削减5%，直到以色列从被占领的阿拉伯土地上撤军，并恢复巴勒斯坦难民的权利。10月，石油输出国组织（OPEC）对运往美国的石油实施了禁运。
The move was in response to US support of Israel during the 1973 Arab-Israeli war. Soon, they were major oil shortages in the United States. The price of gas skyrocketed. Because of the fuel shortage, General Motors has ordered additional layoffs affecting thousands of workers. President Nixon even announced a new limit on interstate highway speeds. I have called upon all the American people to drive their cars at 50 miles per hour. Interstate Highway Speeds. maybe a little longer to make the trip to see your mother-in-law. Maybe that wasn't a good idea. You wouldn't mind taking a little longer. The oil crisis disrupted American life in ways that ranged from the serious to the absurd.
此举是为了回应美国在1973年阿以战争期间对以色列的支持。很快，美国出现了严重的石油短缺。汽油价格飙升。由于燃料短缺，通用汽车下令额外裁员，影响了数千名工人。尼克松总统甚至宣布了州际公路的新限速。我呼吁所有美国人民以每小时50英里的速度驾驶他们的汽车。州际公路限速。去见岳母的路上可能要多花点时间。也许那不是个好主意。你不会介意多花点时间。石油危机以从严重到荒谬的各种方式扰乱了美国人的生活。
There's a governor who's wearing long johns, there's a professor in Georgia who says that if we change the whole television schedule, make it earlier, people will go to bed earlier and save lights. And a Michigan restaurant man wants his customers to ride horseback to dinner and he says, if they do, he'll might throw in a bucket of oats with the meal. All of this meant that Americans started to covet small, cheap cars with excellent gas mileage, like the Ford Pinto. Sales took off and the Pinto became crucial to Ford's bottom line. But the decade that followed would not end well for Ford or the rest of the US car industry.
有一位穿着长内衣的州长，有一位佐治亚州的教授说，如果我们改变整个电视节目表，让它提前，人们就会早点睡觉，从而节省照明。还有一位密歇根州的餐馆老板希望他的顾客骑马去吃晚餐，他说，如果他们这样做，他可能会在餐点里加一桶燕麦。所有这些都意味着美国人开始垂涎那些省油、便宜的小型汽车，比如福特Pinto。销量飙升，Pinto成为福特利润的关键。但随后的十年对福特或美国汽车工业的其他公司来说都不会有好结果。
For the Pinto, its PR troubles began with a recall campaign led by Ralph Nader and a series of journalism exposés. The most widely referenced of these was a 1977 feature in the magazine Mother Jones. The article told the story of a woman and her 13-year-old passenger who suffered a fiery, rear-end crash involving a pinto. The woman was killed and the boy was severely burned. The mother-john's reporter, Mark Dawi, claimed this was not an isolated incident. We estimate that 500 men and women and children have burned to death in Pinto's over the past six years who would not have been seriously injured if the car had not burst into flames. That number, at least 500 deaths since 1971, or slightly more than 80 deaths on average per year, has been hotly debated.
对于Pinto来说，它的公关麻烦始于由拉尔夫·纳德领导的召回运动和一系列新闻调查。其中被引用最多的是1977年《琼斯母亲》杂志的一篇专题报道。文章讲述了一名妇女和她13岁的乘客遭遇了一起涉及Pinto的火灾追尾事故。该妇女死亡，男孩严重烧伤。《琼斯母亲》的记者马克·道伊声称这并非孤立事件。我们估计，过去六年中，有500名男女老少在Pinto车中被烧死，如果汽车没有起火，他们本不会受重伤。这个数字，即自1971年以来的至少500人死亡，或平均每年略多于80人死亡，一直备受争议。
At the time, NPR reported that Ford said the number was pure exaggeration. In 1975, there were 848 deaths associated with passenger car accidents in which fires also occurred in some parts of the vehicle. Only 12 of these 848 reported fatalities involved occupants of pentose. Later, Ford would say pentose had been involved in 35 cases of rear-impact fires. Those fires, the company said, resulted in 23 burn injuries and 21 deaths. An investigation by the National Highway Traffic Safety Administration came up with similar numbers, 24 burns and 27 fatalities. Today, it's still unclear how many people died or were injured in these crashes. Mark Dauy made other charges against the company too.
当时，NPR报道称福特表示这个数字纯属夸大。1975年，在乘用车事故中，车辆某些部位也发生火灾的死亡人数为848人。在这848起报告的死亡事故中，只有12起涉及Pinto车的乘员。后来，福特表示Pinto涉及了35起追尾火灾。该公司称，这些火灾导致了23人烧伤和21人死亡。美国国家公路交通安全管理局的一项调查得出了类似的数字：24人烧伤，27人死亡。今天，仍不清楚到底有多少人在这些事故中死亡或受伤。马克·道伊还对该公司提出了其他指控。
He wrote that Ford had rushed the Pinto into production, coming up with a new model in just over two years, when that process usually took closer to 3.5 years. That shortened time frame, he wrote, had consequences. For one, because of the accelerated schedule, crash testing happened after the basic design was pretty much set. According to the Mother Jones story, these tests revealed that the Pinto was vulnerable in low-speed rear end crashes. Over the years, multiple news organizations, including NPR, have highlighted potential problems with the Pinto's design. Instead of installing the tank to the front of the rear axle where the car's back wheels were mounted, it was placed behind the axle. There is virtually no crush area between the back of the car and the back of the gas tank. Just a few inches of damage to the back end of the car brings the metal of the car or
他写道，福特匆忙将Pinto投入生产，在短短两年多一点的时间里就推出了新车型，而这一过程通常需要接近3.5年。他写道，缩短的时间框架带来了后果。首先，由于进度加快，碰撞测试是在基本设计基本定型后才进行的。根据《琼斯母亲》的报道，这些测试显示Pinto在低速追尾碰撞中很脆弱。多年来，包括NPR在内的多家新闻机构都强调了Pinto设计中潜在的问题。油箱没有安装在后轴前方（即汽车后轮安装的位置），而是被放置在后轴后面。车尾和油箱后部之间几乎没有缓冲区域。车尾受到哪怕几英寸的损坏，就会使汽车的金属或
the object that's producing the impact right up against the gas tank. Some have argued that the Pinto's design wasn't much different from that of other small cars being produced by American car companies. But there was one feature that made the Pinto stand out from the herd, the studs. They're up at the top of the tank. They are again directly ahead of the splash pan on the back of the car with no protection whatsoever. They're one of the first things that actually gets hit, but they're designed in such a manner that as they bend forward, they can be pushed through the rear of the gas tank,
产生撞击的物体直接撞上油箱。一些人认为，Pinto的设计与美国汽车公司生产的其他小型汽车并没有太大区别。但有一个特征使Pinto在同类产品中脱颖而出：螺柱。它们在油箱顶部。它们再次直接位于车尾防溅板的前面，没有任何保护。它们实际上是第一批被撞击的东西，但它们的设计方式使得当它们向前弯曲时，它们会被推入油箱后部，
rupturing the tank. These were bolts that protruded from the rear axle, menacingly close to the low-hanging fuel tank. If a pinter was hit from behind, even at low speed, these bolts could poke holes in the fuel tank. If that happened, oil could spill out and ignite at the smallest spark. One lawyer called the studs, can openers. The final charge that marked how he made against Ford had to do with the company Memo that
导致油箱破裂。这些是从后轴突出的螺栓，危险地靠近低悬的油箱。如果Pinto被追尾，即使是低速，这些螺栓也可能在油箱上戳出洞来。如果发生这种情况，汽油可能会溢出并在最小的火花下点燃。一位律师称这些螺柱为“开罐器”。马克·道伊对福特提出的最后指控与一份公司备忘录有关，该备忘录
came to be infamous. The memo laid out a cost-benefit analysis showing that fuel leakage in certain crashes could potentially be prevented with alterations that would cost about $11 per car. But the analysis determined that the cost of implementing these changes would not outweigh quote, expected benefits. Here, the word benefit meant the potential for lives saved and injuries avoided. In making its calculations, Ford valued a human life at about $200,000, a number borrowed from a report by the National Highway Traffic Safety Administration. The memo did not refer specifically to the Pinto. The calculations likely included all American cars.
变得臭名昭著。该备忘录列出了一项成本效益分析，显示在某些碰撞中，通过每辆车花费约11美元的改动，可以潜在地防止燃料泄漏。但分析确定，实施这些更改的成本不会超过所谓的“预期收益”。在这里，“收益”一词意味着挽救生命和避免伤害的潜力。在进行计算时，福特将人的生命价值定为约20万美元，这个数字借用了国家公路交通安全管理局的一份报告。该备忘录并未专门提及Pinto。这些计算可能包括了所有美国汽车。
Regardless, Mark Dauy's coverage of the memo painted a picture of Ford as a company that was willing to prioritize profits over safety. The 1991 movie class action is based in part on the story of the Pinto. It depicts a car company making a cost-benefit analysis. You have a defective part. You make a decision whether to replace that part in a recall or suffer the consequences of a lawsuit, whichever's cheaper.
无论如何，马克·道伊对该备忘录的报道将福特描绘成一家愿意将利润置于安全之上的公司。1991年的电影《因果报应》部分基于Pinto的故事。它描绘了一家汽车公司进行成本效益分析的情景。你有一个有缺陷的零件。你决定是通过召回更换该零件，还是承担诉讼的后果，哪个更便宜。
Is that correct? Ford faced a slew of civil lawsuits relating to Pinto rear end collisions. There was even a criminal trial. In Indiana Ford was indicted for three felony counts of reckless homicide for the accident that killed Judy, Lynn and Donna Ulrich, the three teenagers whose story we heard at the top of the episode. Ford was found not guilty, but the Pinto never really recovered its reputation.
这是正确的吗？福特面临着一系列与Pinto追尾碰撞相关的民事诉讼。甚至还有一场刑事审判。在印第安纳州，福特因导致Judy、Lynn和Donna Ulrich死亡的事故被控三项鲁莽杀人罪，这三名少女的故事我们在本集开头就听到了。福特被判无罪，但Pinto再也没有真正恢复其声誉。
The car would go on to become the butt of jokes everywhere, in movies, on late-night TV, and in cartoons on newspaper editorial pages. In May of 1978, a federal agency issued an initial determination that the Pinto's fuel system was defective. The National Highways Traffic Safety Commission yesterday issued a tentative finding that 1,930,000 Ford Pintos and Mercury Bobcats may be dangerous. Not long after, Ford agreed to voluntarily recall one and a half million Pintos. The story of the Fort Pinto, seen from the vantage point of today, is almost a parable. It's seen as a warning sign about the risks of hubris and averis.
这款车后来成了电影、深夜电视节目和报纸社论版漫画中随处可见的笑柄。1978年5月，一个联邦机构发布了一项初步裁定，称Pinto的燃油系统存在缺陷。国家公路交通安全委员会昨天发布了一项初步调查结果，称193万辆福特Pinto和水星Bobcat可能存在危险。不久之后，福特同意自愿召回150万辆Pinto。从今天的角度来看，福特Pinto的故事几乎是一个寓言。它被视为关于傲慢和贪婪风险的警示标志。
But as I said, our story today is not about the Pinto. It's not about relitigating what Ford knew and when. It's about how we think about the past. When we come back, what psychology reveals about the mind of a Ford insider who voted not to recall the Pintel and is now haunted by the choices he made. Denny Joya came of age during an era of big changes in the United States. I was marching for civil rights, for women's rights, and against the attitude of big business at the time. He had long hair and wanted to make the world a better place. He started with
但正如我所说，我们今天的故事不是关于Pinto。它不是关于重新审视福特知道什么以及何时知道的。它是关于我们如何思考过去。当我们回来时，心理学将揭示一位投票决定不召回Pinto、现在被他所做的选择所困扰的福特内部人士的内心世界。Denny Joya在美国发生巨大变革的时代长大。我当时正在为民权、妇女权利以及反对当时大企业的态度而游行。他留着长发，想让世界变得更美好。他从
the classes in his MBA program. I was the guy who would speak up and saying, shouldn't we account for the employees or the customers in this situation? In 1972, Denny cut his hair and took his first corporate job with the Ford Motor Company. He loved cars and he thought by becoming an insider, he might be able to shape Ford for the better. I decided, with intent, to try to change this lumbering behemoth from the inside out. He rose quickly at Ford, propelled by his expertise and his competitive spirit. About a year in, he was just 26. Denny became Ford's recall coordinator. So you were 26 and you were playing a role to
他的MBA课程开始。我是那个会站出来说“在这种情况下，我们难道不应该考虑员工或客户吗？”的人。1972年，Denny剪掉了头发，在福特汽车公司获得了第一份企业工作。他热爱汽车，认为通过成为内部人士，他也许能让福特变得更好。我下定决心，试图从内部改变这个笨重的庞然大物。他凭借自己的专业知识和竞争精神在福特迅速崛起。大约一年后，他才26岁。Denny成为了福特的召回协调员。所以你当时26岁，你扮演了一个角色来
basically decide where the cars get recalled? I mean, that's astonishing. Never occurred to me that it was astonishing, but yeah, I guess it was. I was rather low in the hierarchy, but it was an extraordinarily powerful position in the sense that if I picked up the phone and called anybody and identified myself as Danny Joya from the recall office, people jumped. And it got to be pretty interesting to watch people who were ranked much higher than I was in the organization, leap to fulfill my every need. But that was the nature of the job. And it was a very important job.
基本上决定汽车在哪里被召回？我的意思是，这太令人震惊了。我从来没觉得这很令人震惊，但是的，我想确实是。我在等级制度中处于相当低的地位，但在某种意义上，这是一个极其强大的职位，因为如果我拿起电话打给任何人并表明我是来自召回办公室的Denny Joya，人们就会立刻行动。看着那些在组织中级别比我高得多的人急于满足我的每一个需求，这变得非常有趣。但这就是工作的本质。这是一份非常重要的工作。
I had to track everything that might become a recall. And so I started a file on everything, and the information for those files came from field reports. Ford had a series of field engineers, as I recall, the R2 in every state, and their job was to fill out a sheet identifying a potential problem, and they would send it to me. Denny would pour through crash reports, looking for patterns of something going wrong over and over again.
我必须追踪所有可能成为召回事件的事情。所以我开始为每件事建立档案，这些档案的信息来自现场报告。据我回忆，福特在每个州都有系列现场工程师，他们的工作是填写一张识别潜在问题的表格，然后寄给我。Denny会仔细阅读碰撞报告，寻找反复出现的问题模式。
Breaks failing, wheels falling off, axles detaching and startling drivers, he had to keep a file on everything. But he was always on the lookout for two specific things. I had two criteria for deciding what should be a recall. One was what I called traceable cause. Something had to be breaking. I mean, I'm an engineer. You can't just engage in magical thinking because somebody somewhere says that there's a problem. You have to have evidence. So I had to have documentation that something was breaking and I had to see a pattern of failures. I never went to recall unless I had at least 20. In other words, he needed more than anecdotes.
刹车失灵、车轮脱落、车轴断裂并惊吓到司机，他必须为每件事保留档案。但他总是留意两件具体的事情。我决定什么应该召回有两个标准。一个是所谓的“可追溯原因”。必须有东西坏了。我的意思是，我是个工程师。你不能仅仅因为某人某处说有问题就陷入某种魔法思维。你必须有证据。所以我必须有文件证明有什么东西坏了，而且我必须看到故障模式。除非我至少有20个案例，否则我从不召回。换句话说，他需要的不仅仅是轶事。
He needed data. If he had evidence and could identify a pattern, then he would put the case up for a vote, to recall or not to recall. There were five people in his office, and everyone got a vote. If they voted to recall, he would send the case up to a high-level executive committee that would make the final decision. If the committee agreed with Denny's group, he would then initiate a recall. By the time Denny became Ford's recall coordinator, the Pinto had been on the market for about
他需要数据。如果他有证据并能确定一种模式，那么他就会将案件提交投票，决定是否召回。他的办公室里有五个人，每个人都有一票。如果他们投票决定召回，他就会将案件提交给一个做出最终决定的高层执行委员会。如果委员会同意Denny小组的意见，他就会启动召回。当Denny成为福特召回协调员时，Pinto已经在市场上销售了大约
three years. In retrospect, we know so much about the Pinto that Denny did not know in the early 1970s. We know it would soon become one of the most hated cars in America, the subject of journalistic and federal investigations, and eventually a national recall. At each 26, Denny did not know any of that. Nor he says did he know about any of the early crash tests or design flaws that were later detailed in the Mother Jones Exposé. To the Denny of 1973, the Pinto was just another car that came
三年了。回想起来，我们对Pinto的了解远多于Denny在1970年代初所知道的。我们知道它很快就会成为美国最令人讨厌的汽车之一，成为新闻和联邦调查的对象，并最终导致全国范围的召回。在26岁时，Denny并不知道这一切。他说，他也不知道后来在《琼斯母亲》调查报道中详细描述的任何早期碰撞测试或设计缺陷。对于1973年的Denny来说，Pinto只是另一辆车，
up from time to time in reports. Early on, the Pinto wasn't even really on his radar until I got a filled out field report that was different from any I had ever seen. That had photographs stapled front and back from an engineer and he said to me, I spent all day on this God-for-sacant car. I can't find a thing wrong with it, except that it's a tin can. By which he meant, it's a little car, got hit by a big car, it lit up, what did you expect?
不时出现在报告中。起初，Pinto甚至没有真正进入他的视野，直到我收到一份与我见过的任何报告都不同的现场报告。上面订着前后照片，来自一位工程师，他说：“我整天都在研究这辆该死的车。我找不到它有什么问题，除了它是个铁皮罐头。”他的意思是，它是一辆小车，被大车撞了，它着火了，你还指望什么？
The car had caught fire in a collision. Now, Danny had an incident, but still no cause, and definitely no pattern. So he did what he always did. He started a file on the pinto and began to track it. Danny took his job as recall coordinator seriously. When he first started in the role, he would wake up at night and stare at his bedroom ceiling, worried that he might have made a decision that day that hurt someone. That feeling eventually went away. It had to. You can't have emotions rise to the surface if you're going to be an effective recall coordinator. You've got to get over that. How do you get over having an emotional response to somebody? Somebody dying in one
这辆车在碰撞中起火了。现在，Denny有了一个事件，但仍然没有原因，更没有模式。所以他做了他一贯的做法。他为Pinto建立了一个档案，并开始追踪它。Denny认真对待他作为召回协调员的工作。当他刚开始担任这个角色时，他会在夜里醒来，盯着卧室的天花板，担心自己那天可能做出了伤害某人的决定。那种感觉最终消失了。它必须消失。如果你想成为一名有效的召回协调员，你就不能让情绪浮出水面。你必须克服它。你如何克服对某人的情感反应？有人死在你的
of your products? Well, it's not easy, but you do it. Not long after he started his file on the Pinto, Denny had an encounter that challenged his efforts to stay focused on the data rather than his feelings. It happened in a company warehouse that Ford Insiders called the Chamber of Horrors. That's where all the horrible pieces came that had broken and often hurt or killed somebody. I was out there one day when I saw a burned out pinto off in the corner under a tarp. I don't know if you've ever seen a burned out car. I have not. No. Everything's melted. All the upholstery is gone, burned away. The paint is burned off, the wiring is melted,
产品里？嗯，这不容易，但你做到了。在他开始Pinto档案后不久，Denny遇到了一次挑战，这挑战了他专注于数据而不是感受的努力。这发生在一个福特内部人士称为“恐怖之室”的公司仓库里。那是所有坏掉的、经常伤害或杀死某人的可怕零件存放的地方。有一天我在那里时，我看到角落里有一辆被防水布盖住的烧毁的Pinto。我不知道你是否见过烧毁的汽车。我没有。不。一切都融化了。所有的内饰都不见了，烧光了。油漆烧掉了，电线融化了，
the glass is melted, the steering wheel is melted. And when you learn that that car was actually a death vehicle, it will turn your stomach. Still, when he got back to the office and looked in his Pinto file, he only had five cases involving rear end fires. He had no identifiable cause or pattern. In other words, he was nowhere near his usual standard for recommending the case for a recall vote.
玻璃融化了，方向盘融化了。当你得知那辆车实际上是一辆死亡车辆时，它会让你反胃。尽管如此，当他回到办公室查看他的Pinto档案时，他只有五起涉及追尾火灾的案例。他没有可识别的原因或模式。换句话说，他离他通常推荐召回投票的标准还差得很远。
But he decided to do it anyway. So despite my training, when I saw that car, and despite the fact that I only had five field reports, I nonetheless put it on the docket for a vote. And when you brought it up to the five-person committee, was there a robust argument? Was there a discussion? Did people just sort of roll their eyes at you?
但他还是决定这么做。所以尽管受过训练，当我看到那辆车时，尽管我只有五份现场报告，我还是把它列入了投票议程。当你把它提交给五人委员会时，有激烈的争论吗？有讨论吗？人们只是对你翻白眼吗？
What would actually happen? Oh, I could have's a good description. Yes, they roll their eyes at me. Why are we doing this? Because you had an emotional response to seeing a burned out Pinto, that's, that's not good enough. We got to have data. How many you got?
实际上会发生什么？哦，我能描述得很好。是的，他们对我翻白眼。我们为什么要这样做？因为你看到一辆烧毁的Pinto产生了情感反应，那，那不够好。我们必须有数据。你有多少个？
What's the pattern? That's not a pattern. Those could all be outliers. If you're an engineer, you have to think that way. Now, there's actually, you know, you can criticize this, but you can also say this is actually the correct way to think, because of course anecdotally, things happen all the time that are idiosyncratic to a particular car or a particular situation, the weather conditions might be bad, something happens. And if you basically base your judgments on one case, I mean, presumably we'd be recalling every car off the road,
模式是什么？那不是模式。那些可能都是异常值。如果你是工程师，你必须那样思考。现在，实际上，你知道，你可以批评这一点，但你也可以说这实际上是正确的思考方式，因为当然，轶事上，事情总是发生，对于特定的汽车或特定的情况是特有的，天气条件可能很糟糕，发生了什么事。如果你基本上根据一个案例来做出判断，我的意思是，大概我们会召回路上所有的汽车，
because every car is probably going to have some idiosyncratic case where something goes wrong, no? Oh, absolutely. Now, now think about this. We're looking at a car that has been built in the cheapest way possible. And given that it's a cheap vehicle, you can identify 50 things that cost five to ten dollars to fix. If you want to take a blanket approach and fix everything, suddenly you've got a car that nobody's willing to buy.
因为每辆车可能都会有一些特有的案例，出现问题，不是吗？哦，当然。现在，现在想想这个。我们正在看一辆以最便宜的方式制造的汽车。鉴于它是一辆廉价车辆，你可以找出50个花费5到10美元就能修复的问题。如果你想采取一刀切的方法并修复所有问题，突然间你得到了一辆没人愿意买的汽车。
That's not okay, especially in an era when the only thing people are buying is a Pinto. When it came down to a vote, Denny's office elected 5-0, not to recall. Even Denny voted against himself. Even Denny voted against himself. It wasn't until about a year later that Denny says something strange happened. Denny says that one day in 1974 he walked into his office and saw a report lying upside down on his desk. It turned out to be an old engineering report from 1970, the early days of the Pinto, that showed why the cars were catching fire. By now, you can probably guess the culprits, the low-hanging fuel tank, and the studs that could rupture the tank like a can opener.
那是不行的，尤其是在人们唯一买得起的就是Pinto的时代。当投票时，Denny的办公室以5比0投票决定不召回。甚至Denny也投了反对票。甚至Denny也投了反对票。直到大约一年后，Denny说发生了一些奇怪的事情。Denny说，1974年的一天，他走进办公室，看到一份报告倒扣在他的桌子上。结果发现那是1970年的一份旧工程报告，那是Pinto的早期，显示了汽车为什么会起火。现在，你可能已经猜到了罪魁祸首：低悬的油箱，以及像开罐器一样能刺破油箱的螺柱。
It was what I call a slap-your-for-head moment, because it revealed that the Pinto's rear axle was an off-the-shelf component, which is to say it was used in some other application by the Ford Motor Company. That application was the Ford of Europe Capri. That car was more complicated. It had anchor points, called studs, on the rear axle to which suspension arms were attached. But when it was used in the Pinto, they didn't need those suspension arms, so they deleted them.
这就是我所谓的“拍脑袋”时刻，因为它揭示了Pinto的后轴是一个现成的组件，也就是说，它被福特汽车公司用于其他应用。那个应用是福特欧洲的Capri。那辆车更复杂。它在后轴上有称为螺柱的锚点，悬挂臂连接在上面。但当它被用于Pinto时，他们不需要那些悬挂臂，所以他们删除了它们。
But they did not delete the studs to which the suspension arms were attached. The bolts were intended for a different kind of car with a different design. So what happened when the car was hit from behind at the federally mandated speed of 50 kilometers or 31 miles an hour. The fuel tank got pushed and got punctured by these four studs that were protruding. Wow. If the accident was anywhere over 25 miles an hour, it ripped the fuel filler neck out, sprayed gasoline all over the place, including into the rear seats. If there's a spark anywhere in the vicinity, it's going to light up. Secondly, if it's anything over 25 miles an hour,
但他们没有删除连接悬挂臂的螺柱。这些螺栓是为另一种设计不同的汽车准备的。那么当汽车在联邦规定的每小时50公里或31英里的速度下被追尾时会发生什么呢？油箱被推挤，并被这四个突出的螺柱刺破。哇。如果事故速度超过每小时25英里，它就会撕裂加油颈，把汽油喷得到处都是，包括后座。如果附近有火花，它就会点燃。其次，如果速度超过每小时25英里，
it's going to, it's going to accordion the car. The doors get pinned shut. So you're trapped in a car that is just exploded into a fireball and you cannot get out. My God. This is a very ugly accident. Today, Denny says he still does not know who put the engineering report on his desk. But in 1974, he knew what he had to do. He called Ford's executive committee overseeing recalls. And I said, in effect, get ready. We've got a big one coming. Denny says Ford decided to see how the Pinto compared to other cars in the industry. According to Denny, Ford bought some competitor cars with layout similar to the Pinto,
它会把车挤成手风琴状。车门被卡住。所以你被困在一辆刚刚爆炸成火球的汽车里，你无法逃脱。天哪。这是一起非常丑陋的事故。今天，Denny说他仍然不知道是谁把那份工程报告放在他桌上的。但在1974年，他知道他必须做什么。他打电话给负责召回的福特执行委员会。我实际上说，准备好。我们要迎来一个大事件了。Denny说福特决定看看Pinto与其他行业汽车的比较。据Denny说，福特购买了一些布局类似于Pinto的竞争对手汽车，
but without the start problem, and tested them. And what they found was the average speed at which those cars fuel tanks would rupture. Was about 27. half miles an hour. Wait, almost the same. Pretty close. 25 versus 27 and a half. So what do you do now? Let me put you in the position
但没有螺柱问题，并对它们进行了测试。他们发现这些汽车油箱破裂的平均速度约为每小时27.5英里。等等，几乎一样。非常接近。25对27.5。那么你现在做什么？让我把你放在
of being the recall coordinator. How would you vote? Would you vote to spend $30 million for two and a half miles an hour? Now it leads to a really interesting dilemma because when you hear these numbers, you can get sucked in. You can go, the math doesn't add up. And yes, human lives are at stake, but what's the value that should prevail here? So if it's a values-based decision, of course you recall.
召回协调员的位置上。你会怎么投票？你会投票花3000万美元来换取每小时2.5英里的差距吗？现在这导致了一个非常有趣的困境，因为当你听到这些数字时，你可能会被卷进去。你会想，数学加起来不对。是的，人的生命危在旦夕，但这里应该优先考虑什么价值？所以如果这是一个基于价值的决定，你当然会召回。
Of course you recall. But if it's a business decision, do you spend $30 million for two and a half miles an hour when the cars that have a problem are not statistically significantly different from the cars that don't? I don't know what to do. Still, Denny had to make a decision and for the second time, he voted not to recall the Pinto. Denny left Ford in 1975. Three years later, Ford admitted there was a problem and recalled the car.
你当然会召回。但如果这是一个商业决定，当有问题的汽车与没有问题的汽车在统计学上没有显著差异时，你会花3000万美元来换取每小时2.5英里的差距吗？我不知道该怎么办。尽管如此，Denny还是必须做出决定，他第二次投票决定不召回Pinto。Denny于1975年离开福特。三年后，福特承认存在问题并召回了该车。
When we look back at moments in our lives that turned out badly, it can be easy to say what we might have done differently. We zero in on the moment things went wrong and say, that's what did it. That's the moment I would go back and change. In hindsight, it all seems like common sense. But what if it isn't so simple? What if these thoughts say less about the past and more about us, about the comfort we seek in dealing with a chaotic and unpredictable world?
当我们回顾生活中那些结果糟糕的时刻时，很容易说出我们本可以采取不同的做法。我们专注于事情出错的时刻，并说，那就是原因。那就是我会回去改变的时刻。事后看来，这一切似乎都是常识。但如果并非如此简单呢？如果这些想法对过去说得少，而对我们自己说得多，关于我们在处理一个混乱和不可预测的世界时所寻求的安慰呢？
Stay with us. When something good happens, we tend to think that everything that led up to it was also good. If a rocket launch is successful, then we assume all the preparation and engineering that went into it must have been handled well too. And when something bad happens, let's say a plane crashes or a company goes bankrupt, our first question usually is, who messed up? Hidden in this question is an assumption many of us make. If there's a bad outcome, then the processes that led up to it must have been flawed too. So when we think about the fiery accident that killed the three Ulrich girls in 1978, it's easy to look at someone like Denny Joyer and say, there must have been something in his recall process that was rotten.
请继续关注。当好事发生时，我们倾向于认为导致它的一切也都是好的。如果火箭发射成功，那么我们假设所有的准备工作和工程设计也一定处理得很好。而当坏事发生时，比如飞机坠毁或公司破产，我们的第一个问题通常是：谁搞砸了？这个问题中隐藏着我们许多人做出的一个假设。如果结果很糟糕，那么导致它的过程也一定是有缺陷的。所以当我们想到1978年导致三名Ulrich女孩死亡的火灾事故时，很容易看着像Denny Joya这样的人说，他的召回过程中一定有什么腐烂的东西。
Some big failure or misstep that he could and should have prevented. But an engineer at On Sociologist Duncan Watts says we shouldn't jump to that conclusion so quickly. He says this way of thinking reveals something fundamental about the way we often fail to understand the past and plan for the future. To explain this idea, Duncan tells a story about another car crash. This is a terrible story and I picked it because it's a terrible story. This time instead of a Ford Pinto, the car is a minivan.
一些他本可以也应该预防的重大失败或失误。但社会学家Duncan Watts说，我们不应该这么快就下结论。他说，这种思维方式揭示了我们经常无法理解过去和规划未来的一些根本性问题。为了解释这个想法，Duncan讲了一个关于另一起车祸的故事。这是一个可怕的故事，我选择它是因为它是一个可怕的故事。这一次，不是福特Pinto，而是一辆小型货车。
It's the summer of 2001 in Brooklyn. Joseph Gray is wrapping up an overnight shift at the precinct where he works as a police officer. I was actually supposed to be golf that day and it was kind of like overcast and drizzling a little bit in the morning. This is Steve from an interview Joseph Gray did a few years later with a statin island advance. When Joseph's golf plans are cancelled... He decided to have a couple of beers with his colleagues. We wound up in a bar and then, you know, that was that. And a couple of beers turns into 12, 13, 15 beers, he spends all day drinking and then he
那是2001年的夏天，在布鲁克林。Joseph Gray正在结束他在警察局的夜班。我那天本来应该去打高尔夫球，早上有点阴天，还下着毛毛雨。这是Steve在几年后对Joseph Gray的一次采访中提到的。当Joseph的高尔夫计划取消时……他决定和同事喝几杯啤酒。我们最终进了一家酒吧，然后，你知道，就是那样。几杯啤酒变成了12、13、15杯，他喝了一整天，然后他
gets in his mini van and he drives home. So he's well, well, over the limit, more than double the legal limit. And on the way home, he has the terrible accident. I remember going to hit the brakes as soon as I saw somebody able to buy that and just to lay. He runs a red light and he hits a young family. These next details are hard to describe. Maria Herrera and her 16-year-old sister are crossing the street. They are killed instantly. Maria's four-year-old sister, crossing the street. They are killed instantly. Maria's four-year-old son is with them.
上了他的小型货车，开车回家。所以他远远超过了限制，超过法定限制的两倍多。在回家的路上，他发生了可怕的事故。我记得一看到有人能买到那个，我就去踩刹车，只是延迟了。他闯了红灯，撞上了一个年轻家庭。接下来的细节很难描述。Maria Herrera和她16岁的妹妹正在过马路。她们当场死亡。Maria四岁的儿子和她们在一起。
His body is dragged 100 feet under the Minivan's bumper. Maria is also eight months pregnant. Later, her child is delivered by Cesarean section, but he doesn't survive. Joseph Gray is a face of a criminal trial and he is just, you know, understandably demonized by the media, by the family of the victim, by her husband. Eventually, Joseph receives a maximum sentence of 15 years. At the time, a lot of people felt that wasn't long enough, like Joseph was getting off easy.
他的身体被拖在小型货车的保险杠下100英尺。Maria也怀孕八个月了。后来，她的孩子通过剖腹产出生，但他没有活下来。Joseph Gray面临刑事审判，他被媒体、受害者家庭、她的丈夫妖魔化，这是可以理解的。最终，Joseph被判处最高15年监禁。当时，很多人觉得这还不够长，好像Joseph逃脱了惩罚。
What punishment could possibly be severe enough for such a terrible accident? But pay attention to this word, accident. We want to think that this incident was caused by Joseph Grey's recklessness, and of course, it was. But what's harder to think about are all the other things that had to happen for the accident to occur. What if it hadn't been raining that morning and Joseph Gray went golfing instead of to the bar?
什么样的惩罚才足以应对如此可怕的事故？但请注意这个词：事故。我们想认为这起事件是由Joseph Gray的鲁莽造成的，当然，确实如此。但更难思考的是导致事故发生的所有其他事情。如果那天早上没下雨，Joseph Gray去打高尔夫而不是去酒吧呢？
What if he went to the bar and got drunk, but the bartender had told him he couldn't drive and called him a cab? What if he had started driving, but got stopped before he hit the Herrera family? Let's imagine that everything that happened happened, except that two minutes before he had the accident, Joseph Gray got pulled over by another police officer. What do you think would have happened?
如果他去了酒吧喝醉了，但酒保告诉他不能开车并帮他叫了出租车呢？如果他开始开车，但在撞到Herrera一家之前被拦下了呢？让我们想象一下，发生的一切都发生了，除了在他发生事故前两分钟，Joseph Gray被另一名警察拦下。你认为会发生什么？
He would have been one of these people who gets caught with a high alcohol level driving and people say, oh, that's really bad. You shouldn't do that. And you know, you should maybe you should lose your license for six months and you should do some community service or, you know, pay a fine. But nobody would say, you're a murderer. You're a monster. In this scenario where Joseph Gregg gets pulled over before he can hurt anyone, there's nothing in his behavior that is any different. He behaves exactly the same way he did in the real-life scenario when he killed Maria and her family. Of course, when Joseph decided to get
他会成为那些因酒精含量高开车被抓的人之一，人们会说，哦，那真的很糟糕。你不应该那样做。你知道，也许你应该吊销驾照六个月，你应该做些社区服务，或者，你知道，交罚款。但没有人会说，你是杀人犯。你是怪物。在这种Joseph Gray在伤害任何人之前被拦下的情况下，他的行为没有任何不同。他的行为与他在现实生活中杀死Maria和她家人时的行为完全一样。当然，当Joseph决定去……
behind the wheel after so many beers, he made it much more likely that something bad would happen. But in the hypothetical situation where no one gets hurt, it's not because Joseph decided not to drink and drive. In this other world, he would have behaved in exactly the same irresponsible way. And nobody would think that he should go to jail for 20 years. Or else, if they do, then there's a lot of people who should be going to jail for 20 years. Anybody who's texting while driving or anybody who's had a few drinks too many, anybody who's distracted, all of these people are potentially going to kill somebody.
在喝了那么多酒之后开车，他大大增加了发生不幸的可能性。但在没有人受伤的假设情况下，这并不是因为约瑟夫决定不酒驾。在另一个世界里，他会以完全相同的不负责任方式行事。没有人会认为他应该坐牢20年。否则，如果他们这么认为，那么很多人都应该坐牢20年。任何开车时发短信的人，或者任何喝多了几杯的人，任何分心的人，所有这些人都有可能杀死某人。
And there's some other random thing out there that is determining whether something bad happens or not. This idea that outcomes might in part be random and the result of good luck or bad luck can make us uncomfortable. When something happens good or bad, we are powerfully motivated to see the hand of intentionality and purpose. This bad thing happened because that bad person did something. Take that away from us and we are left not just with the terror of randomness, but the terror of meaninglessness. People associate randomness with an absence of meaning and I've often actually gotten this response from people
还有其他一些随机因素决定了坏事是否会发生。这种认为结果可能部分是随机的，是好运或坏运的结果的想法，会让我们感到不安。当好事或坏事发生时，我们有强烈的动机去寻找意图和目的的痕迹。这件坏事发生是因为那个坏人做了某事。剥夺了这一点，我们剩下的不仅是对随机性的恐惧，还有对无意义的恐惧。人们将随机性与缺乏意义联系在一起，我实际上经常从人们那里得到这种回应
when I sort of walk them through this logic, they sort of look at me with this tired expression on their face and say, then nothing means anything, right? And I sort of find that to be a strange response because meaning is something that we create. The world doesn't create meaning. The world just does whatever the world does. We're the ones who decide what it means. So if you randomly get on a plane or get bumped onto a different flight one day
当我引导他们理清这个逻辑时，他们会用一种疲惫的表情看着我说，那什么都没有意义，对吧？我觉得这是一种奇怪的回应，因为意义是我们创造的东西。世界并不创造意义。世界只是做它该做的事。是我们决定了它的意义。所以如果你某天随机坐上一架飞机，或者被改签到另一趟航班
and the person you sit next to becomes your spouse, that will be a tremendously meaningful event, right, in your life. But it's still random. In a complex world, random things are bound to happen all the time. Most are mundane, some are delightful, a few are heartbreaking. We are mostly okay when the random shapes the mundane, the traffic light turns red as I pull up at the intersection. But when it comes to good things, and especially when it comes to bad things, the notion that wonderful and terrible things happen for no reason leaves us
而你旁边坐的人成了你的配偶，那将是你生命中非常有意义的事件，对吧？但这仍然是随机的。在一个复杂的世界里，随机事件注定会不断发生。大多数是平凡的，有些是令人愉快的，少数是令人心碎的。当随机性塑造平凡事物时，我们大多能接受，比如我驶向十字路口时红灯亮起。但当涉及到好事，尤其是坏事时，美妙和可怕的事情无缘无故发生的观念让我们
dissatisfied, uneasy. I ask Duncan why he thinks this is. The short answer is I don't know. My best guess is that it's extremely adaptive to believe that you understand the world, right? That you want to think that you know what's going to happen because that means you can get out of bed, you can take action, you can invest in the future. And I think that's probably where it comes from, is that it's just a sort of adaptive response to the uncertainty of the world. Duncan is not saying that Joseph Grace punishment was too harsh or too lenient. He's saying that because we know what happened to the Herrera family, it changes how we think about Joseph Gray's actions. Yes, we might be willing to concede that many
感到不满和不安。我问邓肯为什么他认为会这样。简短的回答是我不知道。我最好的猜测是，相信自己了解世界是非常适应性的，对吧？你想认为你知道会发生什么，因为这意味着你可以起床，可以采取行动，可以投资未来。我认为这可能就是它的来源，它只是对世界不确定性的一种适应性反应。邓肯并不是说约瑟夫·格雷的惩罚太严厉或太宽容。他是说，因为我们知道埃雷拉一家发生了什么，这改变了我们对约瑟夫·格雷行为的看法。是的，我们可能愿意承认许多
random things had to happen for the tragedy to occur, but we prefer to ignore them when we make our calculus of right and wrong. We focus on Joseph Gray's negligence because it gives us a feeling of control. We can do something about Joseph Gray. We can lock him up and throw away the key. We can't do anything about all the other random stuff, and that's terrifying. The same thing could be said of the Fort Pinto. Once something terrible has occurred,
随机事件必须发生才能导致悲剧，但在我们计算对错时，我们更愿意忽略它们。我们关注约瑟夫·格雷的疏忽，因为它给了我们一种控制感。我们可以对约瑟夫·格雷做点什么。我们可以把他关起来，扔掉钥匙。我们对所有其他随机的事情无能为力，这太可怕了。福特平托汽车的情况也是如此。一旦发生了可怕的事情，
it becomes nearly impossible to look back on the actions of the people involved, with any sense of dispassion. Our psychological defense systems demand a tidy explanation. We shrink away from anything that suggests messiness, randomness, uncertainty. randomness, uncertainty. It's possible there was negligence or wrongdoing at Ford. Over the years, some have claimed that Ford didn't intentionally make a dangerous car, while others have argued that the early Pinto crash test revealed that executives at Ford knew the Pinto was a dangerous car even before it left the assembly line.
回顾相关人员的行为时，几乎不可能保持任何冷静。我们的心理防御系统需要一个整洁的解释。我们回避任何暗示混乱、随机、不确定性的东西。随机性，不确定性。福特公司可能存在疏忽或不当行为。多年来，一些人声称福特并没有故意制造危险的汽车，而另一些人则认为早期的平托碰撞测试表明，福特的高管在平托下线之前就知道它是一辆危险的汽车。
We reached out to Ford for comment and they declined our request. But our story isn't about the executives at Ford and what they did or did not know. It's about Denny Joyer, a mid-level employee who says he did not know about the Pinto's fuel tank problem until he discovered the mysterious report on his desk in 1974. Up until that moment, and through the end of his tenure at Ford in 1975, Denny followed a clear process for deciding whether to recall cars. Since the company couldn't initiate a recall every time something went wrong with any car on the road, it needed a system for determining if a problem was a real problem or just a fluke.
我们联系了福特公司寻求评论，但他们拒绝了我们的请求。但我们的故事不是关于福特的高管以及他们知道或不知道什么。它是关于丹尼·乔耶，一位中层员工，他说直到1974年他在办公桌上发现那份神秘报告之前，他都不知道平托的油箱问题。在那一刻之前，以及直到1975年他在福特任职结束，丹尼都遵循着明确的召回决策流程。由于公司不可能在路上任何汽车出现问题时都发起召回，它需要一个系统来确定问题是真正的问题还是仅仅是偶然。
If Denny wanted to recommend a recall, he needed to be able to show two things, evidence that something was broken and a pattern of failure. The Pinto never rose to that standard. Denny sent up red flags about the car twice, but both times he looked at the evidence himself and voted not to recall. You might hear this and think we're letting Denny off the hook. Maybe Denny should have resigned in protest when he saw the burned out Pinto in the company warehouse.
如果丹尼想建议召回，他需要能够证明两件事：某物损坏的证据和故障模式。平托从未达到那个标准。丹尼曾两次对该车发出危险信号，但两次他自己查看证据后都投票决定不召回。你可能会听到这些并认为我们放过了丹尼。也许当丹尼在公司仓库看到烧毁的平托时，他应该辞职以示抗议。
Or maybe he should have blown the whistle to the media when the mysterious report turned up on his desk. Or maybe he should have just voted to recall the Pinto even if it meant ignoring his standard. That last thought has plagued Denny himself. In certain circles I'm a certifiable villain guilty of not protecting innocent, unsuspecting people, driving a patently dangerous car. This is tape from a voice memo Denny sent us in 2019.
或者当那份神秘报告出现在他桌上时，他应该向媒体举报。或者他应该投票召回平托，即使这意味着忽略他的标准。最后一个想法一直困扰着丹尼本人。在某些圈子里，我是个彻头彻尾的恶棍，因为没有保护那些驾驶明显危险汽车的无辜、毫无戒心的人。这是丹尼在2019年发给我们的语音备忘录。
It was in response to a callout seeking stories from listeners who felt haunted by something in their past. Am I haunted by something in their past. the right thing, and voted not to recall the pinto. Denny's conscience is heavy with the same question that Duncan Watts is asking. Just because the outcome was bad, does that mean that Denny did the wrong thing, back when he was at Ford? Do the terrible deaths of the three Ulrich girls mean that Denny's criteria for instigating a recall were
这是为了回应一个呼吁，寻找那些被过去某事困扰的听众的故事。我是否被过去某事困扰。做正确的事，并投票决定不召回平托。丹尼的良心沉重地背负着邓肯·沃茨提出的同一个问题。仅仅因为结果很糟糕，就意味着丹尼在福特时做错了事吗？三位乌尔里希女孩的可怕死亡是否意味着丹尼发起召回的标准是
bad. Or is it possible that sometimes bad things happen even when good people are doing their best? This is very hard to accept psychologically. Bad outcomes cast a halo around everything that came before them and it's next to impossible to see through the halo to reality. Duncan Watts again. So the halo effect shows up in lots of circumstances where, you know, for example, people who are good-looking tend to be rated as more intelligent than people who are not good-looking.
糟糕的？或者是否可能即使好人在尽力而为，有时也会发生坏事？这在心理上非常难以接受。糟糕的结果给之前发生的一切蒙上了一层光环，透过光环看清现实几乎是不可能的。邓肯·沃茨再次说道。所以光环效应出现在许多情况下，例如，长相好的人往往被评价为比长相不好的人更聪明。
Even though looks and intelligence have nothing to do with each other, that is just something that our human psychology does. And the same thing is true for success and failure. So if a company is successful, we look at the things that it's doing and we say, well, those must be really good things, right? Those are good processes. Now that good leadership, good teamwork, good communication, good vision, good execution. And if the same company is not successful, we say, oh, all those things are bad. This halo effect really is very deep and profound and hard to shake, right?
尽管外貌和智力之间没有任何关系，但这只是我们人类心理会做的事情。成功和失败也是如此。所以如果一家公司成功了，我们看看它所做的事情，然后说，嗯，这些一定是很好的事情，对吧？那些是好的流程。现在是好的领导力、好的团队合作、好的沟通、好的愿景、好的执行力。如果同一家公司不成功，我们就说，哦，所有这些事情都很糟糕。这种光环效应确实非常深刻，难以动摇，对吧？
We think we're evaluating a process that led to some outcome, but really we're just reflecting the outcome itself. And this really gets in the way of evaluating processes. The story of Danny Joya is more than just a story about a car company and a defective car. It's a story about how we think about the past and what that means for how we think about the future. When we look back, our minds create stories that explain how events came about. We trace bad things to bad people, good things to good people. We already know how things turned out, so it's easy to
我们认为我们正在评估导致某种结果的流程，但实际上我们只是在反映结果本身。这确实阻碍了对流程的评估。丹尼·乔耶的故事不仅仅是一个关于汽车公司和缺陷汽车的故事。这是一个关于我们如何思考过去，以及这对我们如何思考未来意味着什么的故事。当我们回顾过去时，我们的头脑会创造出解释事件如何发生的故事。我们将坏事归咎于坏人，好事归功于好人。我们已经知道事情的结果如何，所以很容易
telepart the good guys from the bad guys. But notice how this breaks down when we think not of the past, but of the future. Now, we don't have the final outcome to guide our conclusions. Now, things look confusing. Messy. Random. Just like now, everybody's saying, well, of course, we had a pandemic. You know, people were warning about it. If only we'd paid attention to them. We would have stopped this, right? So we really, we have this view that whether we explicitly say it or not, that, you know, there is this thread that goes from the past into the future. We think that there is this one trajectory that the world is going to take.
把好人和坏人区分开来。但请注意，当我们不思考过去，而是思考未来时，这种逻辑是如何崩溃的。现在，我们没有最终结果来指导我们的结论。现在，事情看起来令人困惑。混乱。随机。就像现在，每个人都在说，嗯，当然，我们经历了一场大流行。你知道，人们曾对此发出警告。如果我们早点注意就好了。我们本可以阻止这一切，对吧？所以我们确实有这种观点，无论我们是否明确说出来，你知道，有一条从过去延伸到未来的线索。我们认为世界将沿着这一条轨迹发展。
And if only we were smart enough, we could somehow know what thread that is. And that is wrong. And there is no thread. There is just sort of an infinite cloud of possibilities. The future has not been created yet. What did that infinite cloud of possibilities look like to Denny in 1974? Let's try to time travel back to the Ford recall office that year. Denny is looking through his files on Ford's various vehicles. He looks a little tired, maybe from another sleepless night worrying about work. As we watch him,
如果我们足够聪明，我们就能以某种方式知道那条线索是什么。那是错误的。根本没有线索。只有无限的可能性云。未来尚未被创造。1974年，那片无限的可能性云对丹尼来说是什么样的？让我们试着回到那一年福特的召回办公室。丹尼正在翻阅他关于福特各种车辆的文件。他看起来有点累，也许是因为又一个担心工作的失眠之夜。当我们看着他时，
perhaps he opens his file on the pinto. We can tell it's bothering him, but it has not yet risen to a standard for recommending a recall. So he closes the file and gets back to his other work. This younger Denny does not know what we know, that the file he just put away will be the beginning of a long and terrible ordeal. Of course, even in our imaginary time machine, it's difficult to ignore what we already know. Even Denny, who lived through it, has trouble getting back in his 27-year-old head.
也许他打开了平托的文件。我们可以看出这让他很困扰，但它还没有达到建议召回的标准。所以他合上文件，继续做他的其他工作。这个年轻的丹尼不知道我们所知道的，他刚刚收起的文件将是一场漫长而可怕磨难的开始。当然，即使在我们想象的时间机器里，也很难忽略我们已经知道的事情。即使是亲身经历过的丹尼，也很难回到他27岁时的心态。
So if you were to go back in time right now to make that decision over again based on the data that you're telling me, if you could just go back with your, with, with more maturity and experience, but not necessarily the knowledge of how things turned out for Ford, would you vote differently? The honest answer is I don't know. I told Duncan Watts about the Fort Pinto story, and shared with him Denny's intuition. Denny's a situation where he knows something terrible has happened, but the techniques and rules he had to detect problems
所以如果你现在回到过去，根据你告诉我的数据重新做出那个决定，如果你能带着更多的成熟和经验回到过去，但不一定知道福特后来发生了什么，你会做出不同的投票吗？诚实的回答是我不知道。我告诉了邓肯·沃茨关于福特平托的故事，并与他分享了丹尼的直觉。丹尼处于一种他知道发生了可怕事情的情况，但他用来检测问题的技术和规则
did not alert him that there was a problem. So he's not quite sure right now whether to abandon his rules or to accept that sometimes good rules lead to bad consequences. If you accept the process that they had at the time as the right process, then I think I agree with him, right? Like, you know, it's very hard for him to to unlearn what he knows now, but you know, he can't for sure say that he would have made a different decision because he believes that they had a good process. And it just happens to be a
并没有提醒他有问题。所以他现在不太确定是应该放弃他的规则，还是接受有时好的规则会导致坏的结果。如果你接受他们当时拥有的流程是正确的流程，那么我想我同意他的观点，对吧？就像，你知道，他很难忘记他现在所知道的，但你知道，他不能肯定地说他会做出不同的决定，因为他相信他们有一个好的流程。而这恰好是一个
good process that didn't work in that particular case. All of this begs a question. How much do we really understand about the past? How much can we understand? According to Duncan, not much. That's why he advocates for something called epistemic humility. We should be humble about what we think we know and even humble about what we think we know, and even humble about what we can know. And I think that if we just were more comfortable with not knowing the answers to things, we would be less confident about the answers that we come up with, and we would be less inclined to make confident predictions
在那种特定情况下不起作用的好流程。所有这些都引出了一个问题。我们对过去真正了解多少？我们能了解多少？根据邓肯的说法，不多。这就是他提倡一种叫做认知谦逊的原因。我们应该对我们认为自己知道的事情保持谦逊，甚至对我们认为自己知道的事情保持谦逊，甚至对我们能知道的事情保持谦逊。我认为，如果我们对不知道事情的答案感到更自在，我们对自己得出的答案就会不那么自信，我们也就不会那么倾向于做出自信的预测
based on really shaky assumptions, right? And I believe that would help us to avoid some particularly damaging overreaches associated with hubris. But where does that leave us? What do we do once we realize we don't know as much about the past as we think we do. In a world shaped by epistemic humility, we would commission reports and launch congressional inquiries not just when things go wrong, but also when they go right.
基于非常不稳固的假设，对吧？我相信这将有助于我们避免一些与傲慢相关的特别具有破坏性的越权行为。但这让我们处于什么境地？一旦我们意识到我们对过去的了解并不像我们想象的那样多，我们该怎么办？在一个由认知谦逊塑造的世界里，我们不仅会在事情出错时，而且在事情进展顺利时，也会委托报告并启动国会调查。
We would see that good outcomes can sometimes be produced by bad systems. We would ask how we can fix problems that haven't happened. We might also be more humble when it comes to confident conclusions when things go wrong. Yes, it's easy, pleasurable even, to blame our political opponents or our rivals when tragedy strikes. But it would be more honest to acknowledge that the choices that led to bad outcomes were made in the context of confusion and doubt. The uncertainty we all experience when we think about the future, that same confusion was experienced by Kat Shuknecht and Parth Shah. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Laura Quarral, Jenny Schmidt and Thomas Liu. Engineering support from Joshua Noah. Our unsung hero this week is Erin Register.
我们会看到好的结果有时是由糟糕的系统产生的。我们会询问如何解决尚未发生的问题。当事情出错时，我们在得出自信的结论时也可能会更谦逊。是的，当悲剧发生时，指责我们的政治对手或竞争对手很容易，甚至令人愉悦。但承认导致糟糕结果的选择是在困惑和怀疑的背景下做出的，会更诚实。我们所有人思考未来时经历的不确定性，同样的困惑也被凯特·舒克内希特和帕斯·沙阿所经历。它由塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩编辑。我们的团队包括劳拉·夸拉尔、珍妮·施密特和托马斯·刘。工程支持来自约书亚·诺亚。我们本周的无名英雄是艾琳·雷吉斯特。
Erin is an associate project manager at NPR, but her business cards should probably read person who makes things happen. Erin is the person who brings together different teams from across NPR to make sure the launch of new shows and other big projects go smoothly. Her job is one part hurting cats, one part people management, both difficult tasks that she handled beautifully.
艾琳是NPR的副项目经理，但她的名片上可能应该写着“促成事情发生的人”。艾琳是将NPR各地的不同团队聚集在一起，确保新节目和其他大型项目的发布顺利进行的人。她的工作一部分是像赶猫一样，一部分是人员管理，这两项都是她处理得非常出色的困难任务。
Thanks so much for everything you've done to help us at Hidden Brain, Erin. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you liked this episode, please be sure to share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢你为我们在Hidden Brain所做的一切帮助，艾琳。想了解更多Hidden Brain的内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。